شحنته يورانيوم روسيه للصين تثير مخاوفه
من سباق تسلح نووي عالمي سيما مع تقارير
تتحدث عن نوايا صينيه لاستخدامها بمفاعل
التي كشفت انه بين سبتمبر وديسمبر استوردت
من موسكو كميات كبيره من اليورانيوم هذه
الماده مشاهدينا تستخدم لانتاج
البلوتونيوم الذي يمكن استخدامه بالاسلحه
النوويه الامر الذي اكدته الاستخبارات
الامريكيه واعتبرت ان اليورانيوم سيساعد
بيكين على زياده مخزون الرؤوس الحربيه
النوويه بنحو اربعه اضعاف في السنوات
المقبله مما يسمح للصين بمضاهات الترزانه
النوويه التي تنشرها الولايات المتحده
وروسيا حاليا ويسهم بزعزعه التوازن
العسكري في اسيا حيث تتزايد التوترات بشان
تايوان والسيطره على بحر جنوب الصين يقول
البانت
التعاون مشاهدينا في مجال الدفاع
والتكنولوجيا له مكانه خاصه في العلاقات
وفقا ما قاله رئيس فلاديمير بوتين لنظره
الصيني او اخر ديسمبر العام الماضي هذا
الكلام اقلق واشنطن والامم المتحده
وتحديدا بعد ان توقفت الصين عن الابلاغ عن
مخزونات البلوتونيوم حيث تعمل بكين بسريه
تامه مما اثار الشكوك الدوليه
[موسيقى]